we're now ready to talk about one of the
most famous events in all of world
history that really was the trigger for
world war one or the great war as it was
called back then
so this is a little bit of backdrop in
the austro-hungarian empire formally
annexes
formerly annexes bosnia and herzegovina
bosnia and herzegovina it had already
been occupying it since the late 1800s
since the ottomans were being pushed out
but then in 1908 it formally annexes it
and just as a little bit more of
backdrop as the ottomans were being
pushed out of the balkans as the
ottomans were being pushed out of the
balkans it helped rekindle or or bring
about more hope of forming or of
unifying the hugo slavic people the the
southern slavic people when people talk
about yugoslav
yugoslav they're literally talking about
the southern slavs so that literally
means southern so you had these
nationalistic hopes but now in 1908 it
was already being occupied a significant
state that would be part of a potential
future yugoslav was now formally annexed
by the austro-hungarians now you also
had an independent kingdom
of serbia right here and you could
imagine that this was kind of the home
base of the nationalistic movement if
only we could add if only they could add
the other southern slavic states to this
it could one day turn into a greater
yugoslavia
so in that context we get to 1914
and so let me
draw a little line here so we're getting
to 1914
june
28th which is one of the most famous
dates in all of history and you have the
archduke franz ferdinand and his wife
sophie they're visiting sarajevo which
is now it's an annexed it's an annexed
bosnia
and when they are there there is a ploy
there is a scheme to assassinate them
from a group they're called the young
bosnians they're they're they have ties
to the black hand which is kind of this
this nationalistic group
that has ties many many people say i
mean all of these things are all very
shady and behind the back behind the
scenes but it has has ties to elements
in the kingdom of serbia they attempt to
assassinate archduke franz ferdinand and
it's actually a fascinating story
because the initial assassination
attempt is completely completely botched
there's even one case of a guy one of
the guys who tried to be an assassin
when it gets botched he tries to bite on
a cyanide capsule and then jump into a
river
the cyanide capsule had gone bad the
river was only 10 inches deep and so
they were able to get their hands on him
and one of the conspirators gavrilo
princip at this point once the whole
thing was botched he kind of gives up on
the whole assassination attempt and he's
having literally a sandwich at a cafe in
sarajevo kind of thinking about how
botched their whole attempt was and
while that was happening a mistake on
the part of those planning archduke
franz ferdinand's uh uh
route as he was traveling within
sarajevo has them driving right near
gravila princip so he sees all of a
sudden that they that they've taken the
wrong route that they're driving right
by him again remember his people already
knew that there was an assassination
attempt on him earlier in the day so
they were they should have been more
careful now gabriela princip gets up
puts a sandwich down
and starts walking over to where he sees
archduke franz ferdinand and sophie's
car going now the drivers once they
realized that they had made a mistake
they had taken a less safe route they
tried to back up which makes things even
worse because then the car starts
stalling and gavrilo princip literally
walks up to the car and is able to shoot
archduke franz ferdinand and sophie and
just to give you a sense of how
important this is archduke franz
ferdinand of austria is the heir he's
the he is the nephew of franz joseph who
is the who is who is the ruler of
austria-hungary and so he is the heir to
the empire and so he gets assassinated
by gavrilo princip
so ferdinand
franz ferdinand
ferdinand
assassinated
by gavrilo princip and we have right
over here a picture right after gavrilo
princip i believe this is gabriela
princip right over here right after he
was arrested
and just to get a little sense of how
this was tied to this whole astro this
whole yugoslavian nationalistic movement
this is what he said once he was
arrested i am a yugoslav nationalist
aiming for the unification of all
yugoslavs and i do not care what form of
state but it must be free of austria so
this act this this this assassination
motivated by a nationalistic movement
motivated by a desire to maybe merge
bosnia and herzegovina with serbia and
maybe eventually croatia with bosnia
herzegovina and serbia this
assassination as we'll see in the next
video is the trigger for all of world
war one the reason why it triggers it is
because well
there's many things you can cite you
could argue that many of the empires in
in europe were already already
militarizing already had a desire for
conflict but then you also had all these
alliances that essentially allowed the
dominoes to fall and all of europe and
because they had these empires
essentially much of the world to be at
war with each other